"Keep the Internet Weird"
Rachel White
RACHEL: Hello, everyone.
My talk today is called Keep the Internet
Weird and you'll figure out why a little bit
later on.
My name is Rachel White, I'm a self-taught
developer, artist, technologist, creative,
cyborg, ask me why later, techie evangelist
at Microsoft, nice person and I'm also really
bad an at descriptors talking about myself
is weird.
I'm also @oho on Twitter if you're interested
in more things that I have to say.
So this is going to be my love letter to the
Internet.
I'm going to tell you a story about the things
that I've done, the people that I've met and
the things that have led me to be here on
this stage today.
We're going to start at the beginning.
This, right here, is the VTech Socrates and
it came out in 1998 and it was technically
my first computer.
And it was a video game device that was educational.
You were able to do math problems, interior
design and just decorated houses which has
forever ruined me from playing The Sims, it
was my first tangible experience with connecting
to technology and from then on, I was pretty
much ruined.
This thing, right here, is Are You Afraid
of the Dark, it tail of Orpheus' curse, and
was a tale adventure game that was released
in 1994.
And this is, you're doing typical are you
afraid of the dark stuff, like, searching
for mummies, and I didn't have a computer,
but I had friends who did, like, I was super
hooked to anything that I could get my hands
on.
And then I did got my own computer.
And if you know what this is, this is AOHell
and it's a wares tool.
Now when I get a PC, I was like, now I have
knowledge at my fingertips.
Unfortunately, my dad had AOL, so it was -- but
once I got AOHell I was able to manipulate
some of the code that was in the programs
and do horrible things like post linguistics
into chatrooms that if somebody clicked it,
it would kick them off of their dial-up modem
and then from there I went on to IRC, and
this was when I first really started interacting
with people.
And I chose this screenshot because it's the
first way that I ever pirated things on the
Internet.
These are XDCC bots if anybody remembers what
those were.
Basically an album would be so large so you
would have to send a message to a bot that
had a bunch of compressed files that you would
get it piece-by-piece so if your dial-up got
disconnected because your sister picked up
the phone or whatever, you would be able to
pick it up and abstract it later.
So these were my first experiences communicating
with Apple on the Internet.
Some of it is nice, some of it is illegal,
but basically I was like, yeah, this is rad,
I need to do more.
And then I discovered GeoCities and angel
fire.
I
made
sights for Blink 182 because I was super obsessed
with them and thought they were really cool.
And I also thought I was super punk so I had
animated dolls and stuff.
And one of them was a site when I started
learning how to program.
And I didn't start learning how to program
because I love programming, and I'm going
to go to school, and I want to make a lot
of money.
I just did it out of necessity because I wanted
my voice to be heard, and I wanted to be out
there.
And then I found Web Rings.
So when I started thinking about my journey
and connections with the Internet, I realize
so much of it was the result of exploration
and discovery and it was pretty much because
I was not happy with the life that I had in
rural Florida, the people that were around
me, I didn't get along with.
They didn't have common interests?
But people on the Internet did and I could
find anybody that was interested in any of
the same things that I was.
And I could talk to them and we could exchange
ideas and it was really inspiring.
It was a type of escapism that opened me up
to new ideas.
And when I started making sites on GeoCities
and AngelFire, I realized how fun it was to
learn and share that information.
But then, through Web Rings in about earlyish
2000, I discovered personal sites.
So I saw these networks of extremely well
curated sites, impeccably designed with attention
to detail, carefully written entries and crafted
lists for other people to follow and check
out.
And they weren't just sites like we have personal
sites now.
I'm sure we all have personal sites.
We all have blogs.
This is pre-WordPress.
This is actually a software called Gray Matter
which was in perl and just saved your entries
locally.
But we were educating and helping each other
share knowledge and I wasn't because they
were trying to boost their ego about how much
stuff they knew, or how many things they could,
you know, share out there.
It was people who were self-taught and learning
how their own design, learning how to do their
own scrollable divs and their own link changes.
And it was mostly younger women.
And it was really cool.
And it was really welcoming that you could
be able to find out how to, you know, size
your font the best way so that eight pixels,
or ten pixels looked the coolest.
You could learn how to use grunge brushes
on Photoshop which were, like, the coolest
things ever.
So I found all these other teenagers and I
knew that I really wanted to be a part of
it.
So I still remember the first site that I
came across when I was, like, cool, this is
awesome.
I found this woman, her name is Melissa.
This is gleeb.com and she was the first person
that I really found where I was, like, wow
I really like her entries.
I really, really like the music she likes,
all the things that are really cool.
Also, content warning, this is 2002, 2010,
there might be some bad things in all of these
entries that you will see, fair warning.
I didn't proofread.
I loved all the other sites that she hosted.
A host/hostee relationship is when someone
has their own domain name and then they gave
their space to other people, and you can share.
And usually it's people who would have similar
interests and so I could go to all these other
sites and find people like Melissa that I
identified with, and I wanted to be like Mel,
and I wanted to put my voice out there and
so I did.
This is one of my very first personal sites.
My AIM name was BamAndPontiusChick because
I really loved Jackass.
And I loved throwing things at crowd surfers
and they would kick me in the head.
But this was the first place that I got to
express myself and find other information
and dive into Allyssa explains, and find all
the HTML help they're wanted.
There was people who were willing to just
help people out with their link buttons.
And I eventually grew out of having a hostee
site and I wanted my own domain name.
So I got this one, well, these two.
I finally convinced my parents to let me have
some hosting.
It was probably one and one, or GoDaddy or
something like that.
And then finally I was on my way, I got obsessed
with grunge brushes, as you can see and I
had domain names where things I was inspired
by my favorite lyrics.
So a lot of the domain names were like screamo,
or punk band stuff, or that's unlike M-83
and they're not punk.
It's like the scrollable divs, and the stat
counts, which was the pre-Twitter thing of
how to count how popular you were.
And I was thinking the environment, and how
good it felt to code through the process of
discovery.
And asking questions was encouraged and people
really loved to help.
And I knew that I wasn't the only one.
So, of course, I do everyone does when they
have an idea on the Internet, and I had decided
to write a medium think piece on it.
And I was like, hey, friends, did you have
personal domains, or were you writing HTML
and CSS not for a job in the late '90s, early
2000s?
Talk to me about it!
And they totally did.
And I found a bunch of people had the same
path as me, or a little bit different through
Myspace, Neopets, CSS for Lifejournal, age
he will fire, Geocities, other people who
know the quality of a good paintbrush and
put it was like, cool, all these people similar
to me did the same thing.
I wonder if they learned the same thing.
So I asked, were you doing HTML/CSS/JS in
the early 2000s?
Where did you get your coding info from online?
For me, it was Allyssa Explains and DynamicDrive.
And, again, the explanations were all over
using CSS and a Zen Garden, Webmonkey, Allyssa
explained, DynamicDrive, and View Sore, and
it was still exploratory and fun.
And it made me realize that, obviously, when
communities are nice, more people want to
be a part of them and don't we all want our
communities to be nice because we enjoy the
things that we make, hopefully and we want
other people to contribute to that, too?
I would like to think so.
Which then led me to think, when did communities
stop being nice?
And I found a certain trend in the areas that
I thought it might have been.
And it was about 2007 and 2008 and it's something
that happened, some websites that came out
then.
It's the gameification of knowledge sharing.
And it sucks.
Sure, it's helpful but people aren't necessarily
being helpful because they care about you
and they want to help you; they're helping
you because they want points.
Arbitrary point out on the Internet.
So I know that people make jQuery jokes a
lot and there's nothing wrong with jQuery.
I've written a lot of it.
It's great for people that are learning but
I think people that make these types of jokes,
myself included directly because of the gameification
of sharing.
We're asking for vanilla JavaScript answers
and we're getting jQuery answers not because
somebody cares about us, or wants to help
us.
They just want to be heard.
And yeah, while the jQuery solves the problem,
it doesn't solve my problem and while I think
this is a problem, we can fix it.
What I want is more ideas and more people
is more knowledge sharing.
So yeah, people are getting involved in communities
means more knowledge sharing but when you
add in the gamification, you're taking away
the passion and I think that's pretty bad.
We need more ideas and less echo chambers.
We need more people sharing ideas freely and
encouraging code exploration and less gate-keepered
echo chambers.
So now that we know why things could have
maybe went so horrible.
Let's take a fun little stroll back between
the Internet of then and the Internet of now.
So I'm going to give you some cool site how-toes
for the early 2000s, starting with the coolest
techniques, slices and tables.
Has anybody made a website like this?
Is anybody happy that they never had to do
this again?
So if you're not familiar, basically what
you would do is your designer would lay out
your design in Photoshop.
Responsive design didn't exist, to it didn't
matter.
And then take this slice tool and draw out
the sections that were important.
And you could even have a rollover for each
of these sections.
Who needs CSS because we've got images and
tables.
So there were a lot of sites that looked like
this at the time.
And thanks goodness most of that is over.
The other things that we did, which, obviously,
this is my site with my cool haircut from
2003, lots of absolutely-positioned divs.
It didn't because, you know, we didn't care
about responsive design then.
It wasn't really a thing.
So I could lay out this whole entire site
and throw my grunge brushes all over it and
say, okay, cool, I know where this scrollable
div should go, and xy (0, 0) makes sense because
who's going to maximize the div anyway?
And a lot of people making websites that were
personal, spent a lot of time making really
elaborate websites so you would still have
that image techniques because obviously that
font over on the left side isn't any kind
of web font in 2003.
But it was popular.
But luckily today is better.
We have way more things.
We have way more things than back then with
more people trying to get specs integrated
into browsers.
So if you're starting out, you can start with
things like CSS Grid, Flexbox, Tachyons, because
it makes everything good without even having
to try.
And Base CSS.
So now that we have the layouts covered, we're
going to talk about some really cool fancy
things.
Fancy things like DHTML.
So the application of DHTML was actually introduced
by Microsoft but I swear that's not like,
hey, I work there.
It's just a thing.
And if you have heard the term static site
before, a static site is being just HTML and
CSS, you throw some JavaScript in there and
it manipulates the DOM, guess what, you've
got DHTML.
So difference basically a way for Microsoft
with Internet Explorer 4 to be like, look
how fancy this is, it's so cool!
So you could do fancy things like cursor effects.
So, so while you're mousing around on the
browser, you have these plus signs, or ASCII
characters, or bubbles, or stars, or whatever.
Because you're cool, and you want people visiting
on your site.
But the cool thing is, this is still on DynamicDrive
and so you can go back and look at the old
code and I've put some new code over here.
You know, we're the last talk and I don't
have all day to tell you about how we got
cool star effects but I do have an extremely
cool demo from 2003.
I gotta find which way the browser is.
Cool.
All right.
New York City no.
One sec.
Very busy so here's a really nice one in case
you want to make a site about a celebrity
that you have a crush on, and you want to
let them how how much you want to kiss them.
You can put that cool kissing trail on there.
And here's another one, maybe it's winter
and you want to celebrate the cold weather.
You're going to have maybe some snow falling
and then, you know, maybe you are a really
big fan of scuba diving and you want bubbles
on your site.
So you can do this and more with DHTML and
DynamicDrive which was all just copy and paste
snippets and ridiculousness.
So you're in luck, too, because not only is
today better for DHTML stuff, too, and we're
going to talk about why, literally everything
is better than what you were able to do in
2001 and JavaScript.
Everything that changes the DOM, 3JS is great.
P5, you can do VR in the browser now.
If you told me that in 2005, I would have
been like, sure, okay.
You can even control hardware with JavaScript.
The limits are endless.
So while we've made so many steps with technology,
we still have so much work to do.
The code is changed, but the people haven't.
For the most part, the ways that we communicate
has changed and we have a lot of work to do
to fix the damage that the gamification of
knowledge has shaped some of our dev communities.
There's still the good people who are trying
to help out and create a good community.
So support your communities.
Your local communities, global communities,
other communities that you're not part of,
support them all.
When I started the journey of writing this
talk from the Medium article, to being here
on this stage today, I realized something,
and that's that never in my life have I felt
more supported than I did in the early 2000s
as I do right now.
So I went to JSConf 2014, as my first conference
ever.
I didn't know who Tom Dale was, I
didn't know who they were.
I was just pumped to be there and to learn
and I kept to myself.
This was me lurking behind the dunk tank where
I had dunked everyone.
And I learned so much, and, honestly, this
conference changed my life.
I met this friendly guy and I'm lucky enough
to -- I'm going to get emotional.
He took the time to be nice to me.
And he told me about Brooklyn JS and when
I got back to New York, I went and I met so
many good people that were friendly to me,
and nice to me and they were just like people
that cared.
And they're people that put people before
code.
And I think that's important.
They inspired me.
Whoa!
They inspired me and motivated me that I could
do whatever I wanted as long as I just tried.
And that's really important.
And you can have that, too.
If you don't have the communities available
to you in your area, make them.
There are people out there that are willing
to help make whatever you want to be a welcoming,
and inclusive space.
Trust me.
Reach out to me.
Reach out to the organizers, they're willing
to help.
They'll be more than happy to give that to
you.
And in case you don't know, here are some
helpful communities.
There's WeAllJS which is a really fantastic
organization that is JavaScript focused and
it's inclusive to everyone and it's just really
helpful and nice, and they have a Slack, and
a Twitter, and they have conversations.
And then there's CodeNewbie, which is welcoming
for everyone, every language.
They have chats every week to talk about what
you're learning about programming.
And Chiron just had their first conference
which was called Codelands and it was the
most inclusive event that I've ever been to
in my life and they were applauding people
as they were leaving and it made me feel good
about development.
And there's also First PR, and that's made
with Charlotte and it's encouraging organizations
to encourage tagging on issue cues for things
that people might be able to help out with,
and then there's NodeTogether which Ashley
Williams have started which has taught people
from under-represented minorities, to learn
how to program all over the world and I'm
lucky that she was able to take control of
it, and be able to do that.
So I guess the whole point of keep the Internet
weird to me is don't stifle creativity.
Code exploration is important.
Not being afraid of trying new things is extremely
important.
We need to foster growth in our communities
instead of making people be afraid to be a
part of them.
We need to have people try new things because
they want to try them.
And I have this stickers so if you want them,
keep bother me later.
I have a lot of them.
I actually commissioned these from an amazing
designer called Skull Face because I wanted
some really cool slides and stickers for you.
So in case you want to talk to me after this,
I'm @oho on Twitter, and my GitHub where I
open source everything that I could possibly
be able to open source and comment it if I
can is there.
And then my extremely narcissistic domain
name, Rachelisawesome, and I'm cool online.
Thank you.
And please keep the Internet weird.